[Music]
on this Monday night a prescription
aimed at easing pressure on the Health
Care System the new powers for Ontario
pharmacists the main benefit is for the
patient The Province following suit and
when the Saskatchewan couple's Dream
wedding turns into a nightmare with sun
wing like almost in a day it's like felt
numb their heartbreaking Journey to the
altar deadly airstrike Russia's new
setback in its war in Ukraine and
Northern California's catastrophe it was
like mother nature came alive and
declared war the devastation from
ferocious floods
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight Sonya Sunder good
evening and thanks for joining us a
major new change to health care in
Ontario could help ease the burden of
long wait times patients can now skip
the doctor's office and get a
prescription right from the pharmacy for
13 common ailments several other
provinces have a similar system in place
but as Erica Vela reports it's unclear
if it will actually reduce the strain
for nearly 25 years Metta nachla has
been working as a pharmacist providing
consultations to customers eye infection
allergy fever pain this is the most
common thing for those conditions he was
only able to recommend over-the-counter
medications but that all changed as of
January 1st pharmacists in Ontario are
now able to prescribe medication for 13
common medical ailments including pink
eye cold sores tick bites UTIs and other
conditions it's better because it will
give us more varieties to give the
patients according to the Canadian
pharmacists Association Ontario's the
latest jurisdiction to expand pharmacist
services for minor conditions BC will
follow suit later in 2023 none of it
Northwest Territories are the only two
jurisdictions not offering these kinds
of services the expanded services in
Ontario comes at a time when Canada's
Health Care system is experienced
advancing serious strain with
overcrowded ERS and a shortage of family
doctors it's really important to create
capacity in a Healthcare System helping
to address and alleviate the backlog
within Primary Care as well as emergency
departments but some experts say it's
too soon to tell if this will reduce the
pressure on the Health Care System the
fact is that this has been put on
pharmacists in Ontario at times when
they are also working to their capacity
and so how the patient flows change is
actually one of the really important
things to study and evaluate after these
changes happen the main benefit is for
the patient notla says he still
encourages people to visit their doctors
but for those who can't if they don't
find a walk-in clinic or if the hospital
is busy or One A Day like today most of
the places are closed it's just another
way to assist those seeking treatment in
Ontario many Ontario pharmacists say
they are ready to begin now and the
Ontario pharmacist Association says the
rollout will continue in the coming
weeks and people should contact their
pharmacies ahead of time just to make
sure they will be offering these
Services I'll send it back to you
thanks Erica that's Erica Vela in
Toronto Canada's ban on foreign home
buyers is now in effect commercial
Enterprises and people outside Canada
are barred from buying residential
property in this country for two years
the ban was passed by parliament last
June to help make housing more
affordable a limited Supply bidding wars
and skyrocketing costs have led to an
unprecedented Market violators could
face fines of up to ten thousand dollars
and may be ordered to sell their
property
as sun wing faces a tidal wave of
complaints over canceled flights a
Regina couple is sharing their story
about the airline their upcoming
destination wedding is now in Jeopardy
as Brodie Ratcliffe explains the
uncertainty is adding to what's been a
tumultuous past few years
it was so appropriate to propose at
Leo's because we were there all the time
Mandy canning and Chad clify have been
together for five years and we're
looking forward to walking down the
aisle their plans quickly changed on
December 29th I was actually like almost
in a daze I felt numb Sunwing canceled
all operations to Regina and Saskatoon
putting the couple's magical day on hold
for many this would be a stumbling block
are you ready but for the couple it's
another addition to a long line of
obstacles I got up to go to the
Washington I was able to walk and all of
a sudden I barely made it to there and
uh yeah went completely numb that was in
2020 resulting in a trip to the ER and
an eight-hour surgery it had Chad
struggling to move with more pain Chad
was preparing for surgery number two and
proposed to Mandy knowing what was to
come what had happened after the first
surgery
it was really needed as Chad made his
way to the operating table for a third
time the couple booked a package with
sun wing for their wedding in Mexico
with the worst behind them the day they
had long awaited finally arrived in
January then more bad news the trip of
their dreams canceled I just wanted that
day like I just wanted that day where
you know you have all your girls with
you and all your friends and your you
know my kids and my son was set to walk
me down the aisle in a statement Sunwing
says it would refund all passengers with
trips booked within 30 days
but Mandy and Chad say they are worried
about getting their money back and have
heard nothing from the airline the
couple is still hopeful they can find
another airline to whisk them off to
somewhere Sunny where they can finally
say I do we've talked about you know
getting our our wedding party together
and just having a a ceremony or you know
something like a candle at church at
night or something you know and that
sounds beautiful but
it's I don't know it just feels like
it's not the same it's not the same
Brody Ratcliffe Global News
about 65 000 airline passengers are
stranded in the Philippines after a
power outage forced more than 300 flight
cancellations trips to and from Manila
were either delayed canceled or diverted
an unprecedented technical glitch caused
the outage it's now been fixed but the
backlog has created major delays
turning now to the war in Ukraine and a
new setback for Russia Ukraine is
suggesting it has killed hundreds of
Russian soldiers in a New Year's Eve
airstrike it targeted a key building in
the occupied Donetsk region Russia
claims only 63 people died either way it
is one of the largest mass killings of
troops since Russia launched its
Invasion Redmond Shannon reports
the aftermath of a huge New Year's Eve
airstrike on a school building used by
the Russian army it is about 10
kilometers inside russian-held territory
and Ukraine's Donetsk region a strike so
large that even Russia had to admit it
took place
a military spokesperson saying that 63
Russian servicemen were killed by four
us-made high Mars Rockets Ukraine has
claimed responsibility for hitting the
building and said it is clarifying the
death toll earlier Tuesday Kiev
suggested as many as 400 Russian
soldiers were killed there has to be
some skepticism but I think the fact
that the Russians admitted that 63 died
this is an idea of the scope of the loss
prominent pro-russian military bloggers
claimed that the building where the
troops had gathered on Saturday night
was also used as a storage for
ammunition
the death of the Russian troops happened
as Russian State TV broadcast a
patriotic New Year's special
featuring smiling military leaders in
the audience one Ukrainian MP told
Global News the airstrike indicates
extremely poor judgment from Russia's
military to place so many soldiers in
one place it shows that Russia is you
know Russian army is like a big
dinosaurs massive body and Tiny heads
and very tiny brains inside Alexei
goncharenko spoke from a train on route
to Kiev Ukraine's Capital that continues
to deal with nightly airstrikes
targeting its energy infrastructure Kiev
authorities claim they shot down 39
drones overnight Redmond Shannon Global
News London
a somber day at the Vatican where tens
of thousands are paying their respects
to former Pope Benedict
many began lining up Before Dawn to view
the retired pontiff's body as it lies in
state and Saint Peter's Basilica 12
hours of viewing are scheduled for
tomorrow and Wednesday before the
funeral on Thursday as requested by
Benedict it will be a simple funeral led
by Pope Francis in Saint Peter's Square
Benedict died Saturday at the age of 95.
thank you
thousands also gathered in Brazil to say
goodbye to soccer Legend Pele fans and
mourners gathered inside the stadium his
coffin lies on the pitch where he scored
some of his most spectacular goals the
Wake will continue for 24 hours before
Pele will be buried in a private
ceremony on Tuesday La died last week of
cancer at the age of 82.
and a different sports legend is also
making news tennis champion Martina
Navratilova has been diagnosed with
throat cancer and breast cancer the 66
year old says both were caught early and
she'll start treatment next week
navratilova's first bout with breast
cancer was in 2010.
there's another star facing a Health
crisis coming up the accident that's
left popular actor Jeremy Renner in
hospital
[Music]
Oscar nominated actor Jeremy Renner is
in a Nevada hospital tonight in critical
but stable condition the 51 year old was
injured while plowing snow yesterday
morning according to his representative
it's still not clear what exactly
happened police are still investigating
and say the Avengers and Hawkeye star
was the only person involved in the
accident
when it comes to extreme weather in
North America 2023 is picking up where
last year left off record-breaking rain
has swamped Northern California at least
one person has died and as Jennifer
Johnson reports the worst may be yet to
come
a frightening start to the new year for
residents of Northern California roads
and highways turned into rivers leaving
drivers stranded some forced to stand on
the roofs of their cars scientists blame
a so-called atmospheric River storm for
this historic drenching all of a sudden
my car went dead
dead
and I'm like
in the middle of the river
and there's water all around me Rescuers
saved Danielle Hibbett's life and dozens
of others some by land others by
helicopter airlifting them before they
drowned he was in the water for several
hours before we were aware that he was
missing San Bernardino County Fire Crews
arrived just in time to rescue three
people from this truck stuck in Raging
flood waters this was the wettest New
Year's weekend on record for the area it
was like mother nature came alive and
declared war on Sacramento so much rain
came down in such a short time 11 in
Sacramento broke causing even more
flooding First Responders are now
breaking into submerged cars hoping to
find them empty we're still going
basically car to car of these disabled
Vehicles along the highways of the roads
and uh and clearing them to make sure
that nobody is inside hundreds of homes
also flooded the ground is now so
saturated trees are falling thousands
are without power it's completely
obstructing the roadway and the walkway
for pedestrian Friends The Wicked
weather system also brought massive
amounts of snow nearly 76 centimeters
fell in 24 hours in the Sierra Nevada
region but some welcomed the
precipitation to help drought stricken
California I'm very very grateful for
the rain
but maybe not so much so quick others
are just thankful they survived this is
the New Year I'll never forget a flash
flood warning remains in effect as the
storm system moves to Arizona meanwhile
officials are bracing for even more rain
mid-week in a state where dramatic and
dangerous weather events have become all
too common
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
[Music]
the growing effort to help political
prisoners in Iran
[Music]
Iran nine BC MPS have signed on to
provide political sponsorship to
prisoners in Iran potentially facing
executions there has been four months of
anti-government protests and mass
arrests over the weekend the regime's
security forces reportedly detained
several top-tier football players in a
raid on a New Year's Eve party where
alcohol was served violating an Islamic
ban as nithu gacha reports Canadian MPS
are among a growing number of lawmakers
around the world using sponsorship to
campaign for freedom
down with Islamic Republic in Iran the
calls from Canadian protesters have been
clear
among them a commitment from political
leaders to help prevent the executions
of those condemned to death in Iran
going to be on social media it's going
to be writing on their behalf it's going
to be speaking out on their behalf doing
the things that they would do had they
had the opportunity to have their voice
Talib nor Muhammad is among the bcmps
who responded to those calls with a
joint letter saying they're appalled by
Iran's wrongful imprisonment and
execution of protesters and they opposed
the death penalty in all circumstances
for all people everywhere calling on the
Islamic Republic regime to immediately
establish a moratorium to Halt all
executions each of those MPS endorsing
detained Iranians including Physicians
and medical students targeted for their
support of the uprising a total of 19
names including Iman navabi a surgery
resident mehdi mimar rast a medical
student fahime Karimi a mother of three
it's amplifying their message talking
about who they are talking about what
they did that has got them in this
position French Senator Natalie Goulet
tweeted at nor Muhammad with an image of
a prisoner in Iran saying We join you as
sponsors of mina afshari arrested on
November 14 by the Islamic Republic
regime for not wearing a hijab
parliamentarians all over the world are
watching this German MP has been urging
lawmakers around the world to join the
effort to hold the Islamic Republic
accountable I think it's both the
publicity right now that they don't want
but they also know that they have to
take responsibility if they continue
treating their prisoners and their own
people so cruelly
one of Iran's top-ranked female chess
players now also a Target Sara hadam is
reportedly planning to settle in Spain
after she took part in an international
tournament without a headscarf I follow
Iran very closely and I know that when
prisoners have been sponsored those that
have been released will will tell you
that the sponsorship meant a lot and
that their Interiors backed off and that
they were afforded better treatment as a
result of being remembered by Western
politicians their hope now is to
continue the momentum so more lawmakers
around the world help ensure the names
won't be forgotten
Global News
[Music]
crowning moment next how the coronation
of King Charles could be different than
his late mothers
[Music]
the Royal formerly known as Prince
Charles has been called King Charles for
a few months now and in another few
months his coronation will take place it
hasn't been held yet because a ceremony
of this magnitude takes time to map out
Crystal gemancing Reports on the
preparation anticipation and how this
coronation will differ from his mothers
with the New Year comes new excitement
for the new king it's so much like and
they're only 25 made so I was very lucky
I got it down in London so when you saw
that what was your first reaction I
thought it was fabulous yes I think it's
a very good likeness even his hair is
good isn't it you know it's mean from
pieces of Fine Art to cheeky
Collectibles did you think that looks
like
Margaret Tyler's home in Northwest
London is a shrine to All Things Royal
tell me about your your Affinity your
your obvious love for the royal family
when did that start I think it's not
when I was about four or something like
that my parents were great uh really you
know like in the royal family and so I
picked it up off them Tyler jokes it
takes her hours to dust all of the
pictures cups plates and dolls and her
collection is still growing she'll be
adding more this spring with the
coronation of King Charles III tell me
what um what you're looking forward to
with the coronation
I think
um when they when they say their vows
the vows or coronation oath will be
taken by the King on a Saturday in the
spring May 6 in Westminster Abbey the
reigning monarch holds the formal
position of supreme governor of the
Church of England
[Music]
uphold the law and the church its exact
wording varies depending on the
Sovereign we don't know yet if the king
will recite the same words he heard his
mother Queen Elizabeth the second vow in
1953 when he was just a boy
foreign
December the Saint Edwards Crown was
sent away to be modified for the king
the heavily jeweled world-famous piece
was moved from the Tower of London where
it was protected night and day soon it
will be at the center of the coronation
the crowning moment once the king is
Anointed with holy oil presented with
the Royal orb coronation ring and
scepter King Charles will be the 40th
Sovereign crowd here at Westminster
Abbey Queen consort Camilla will also
play a role in the coronation she too
will be anointed and crowned just as the
queen mother was in 1937 at the
coronation of King George VI this is a
very symbolic ceremony and is one of the
last uh you know ceremonies of its class
still in existence there are many
monarchies around the world still but
those monarchies do not have such an
elaborate or grand ceremony such as the
one for our Sovereign Edward Wang is a
Canadian Royal Observer he attended
celebrations in London marking the
Queen's historic 70-year Reign and
returned in September to pay his
respects after Her Majesty's death
[Music]
King tells us he'll be back again soon
for the coronation I'm very interested
to see the invitees
to the coronation and you know whether
they are given prominent seats just to
Showcase that you know there is a
transition period I want to see
representatives from the Commonwealth I
want to see you know racial diversity
Sexual Orientation Diversity trans
inclusion of the coronation operation
golden orb as the coronation is known to
those planning it is expected to be a
blend of the old with the new
expect to see the gold State coach once
more but the event will likely be a
smaller affair with a shorter service
especially compared to Elizabeth's which
was a sprawling three-hour event it's
going to be exciting I think but I still
wish the queen was there it's a
sentiment shared by many across the UK
and the Commonwealth as her era ends and
another begins the ceremony to finalize
that transition now just four months
away
Crystal gemancing Global News London
and that's global national for this
Monday night I'm Sonia senger tonight
through Canada
we love seeing your Canada so please
keep emailing your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
we hope to see you again tomorrow have a
great night
[Music]